hello and welcome to kyojin's webinar
today my name is jovi chesnick and i am
a senior global market manager here at
kyogen and i'll be your host for today's
webinar
today we will be presenting dr ryan farr
who's a researcher at csiro at the
australian center for disease
preparedness
um before we begin um i have a few
housekeeping things that i need to
discuss with you
the first is uh this disclaimer that i
need to make you aware of and basically
this says that this is a kaijan
sponsored webinar and the views
expressed here are those of the speaker
and not necessarily those of kyogen
for any up-to-date licensing information
and product specific disclaimers
see our
kaiogen kit instructions for use or the
user operation manuals
and you can get those at www.kyogen.com
on our website or you can request them
through our technical services team
so with that i would like to then
introduce dr farr
ryan then is a researcher
um who is studying the host response to
sars cove to infection and in this
particular webinar he's looking
specifically at micrornas and we are
really excited to have you here ryan to
talk to us today thank you for joining
us
g'day everyone thanks for joining us and
thank you to kaijan for inviting me to
give this talk and of course a big thank
you to the lovely joby for that
introduction so i am going to be
chatting to you a little bit about uh
previous uh publication that we've uh
just recently put out around micron a
expression in circulation in covert 19
patients but i'm also going to have a
little bit of a chat to you about
micronas and the basis of why they're
good biomarkers and i'm also putting a
little bit of extra data towards the end
of some very recent stuff that we're
excited to share with you as well so
i'm going to get into it
so first of all yes i work at the csiro
australian center for disease
preparedness so we are a high
containment virology laboratory and
we're located right down at the bottom
end
of
mainland australia right near melbourne
we're about an hour outside of melbourne
in a regional area so
this is us we are a nice big concrete
box um and if it looks like all of these
houses around here are staying well
clear that's kind of a good reason we do
house
quite a lot of highly pathogenic viruses
and we're one of the few
labs or institutes in the world
that's able to work with cellular and
molecular biology right the way up to
large animal research in a bsl2 right
the way to bsl4 containment level
so we work with a large range of
different viruses
including
highly pathogenic influenza at bsl3
um
rabies virus at bsl3 as well and so this
is this is a virus that i've done quite
a bit of work in uh previously
uh we do also do some work in the ebola
and the bsl4 level for the highest level
of containment and of course we work
with everyone's favorite
sar crv2 and vsl three or four depending
on the uh application there
so at the center of all the work that we
do uh is our buyer containment so you
can see a couple of my colleagues there
uh sean and mai lang
in their bsl uh four suits doing some of
the work at that highest level of
containment with their
dedicated air supply there
what also
keeps
us safe when we're doing our work is the
high level of engineering that's
throughout our institute so here's a bit
of a diagram of the institute of acdp
and what you can see is that we need at
least
one two three four different levels of
engineering to actually make one level
of labs run and so we're very reliant
and very appreciative of all the
engineers that work with us um there's a
lot of filtering of air in and out and a
lot of treatment of any sort of waste
product that comes out and if you want
to learn more about our facility you can
head to csiro.au
and have a look at our showcase for this
particular institute
so we'll get into covet 19 so i think um
everyone should know what covert 19 is
now i think
everybody's still being quite affected
by this disease and by this pandemic
but if you have been living under a rock
i will take a bit of time just to have a
chat to you about what it is so covert
19 or coronavirus disease 2019 is a
respiratory disease
caused by sars cov2 which is distinct
from stars cov1 which caused the sars
outbreak back in about 2002.
so what's interesting about this
particular disease that it ranges really
from asymptomatic um you know you have
no idea that you've actually been
infected right the way through to acute
respiratory distress syndrome or odds
and unfortunately death and as of about
september this year
and it's greater than 200 million cases
and four and a half million deaths
worldwide so this pandemic has had
really far-reaching impacts right across
the globe
now i'm part of a team known as host
response and as the name kind of implies
we're pretty interested in the host
response to infectious disease and this
is particularly interesting in terms of
covert 19
because the outcome of this infection
really varies wildly between no disease
right the way through to severe disease
and death and there's been a lot of
research and a lot of interest in why
this occurs why this you know large
variability in the outcomes of this
infection and
what we found is that the host response
to this infection really plays a very
central role in determining the disease
outcome a lot of the previous research
that has come out has focused really
squarely on the pro-inflammatory
cytokines such as 6 la tnf alpha and
il-1 beta and we found that they're
elevated in severe covert 19 cases and
they're considered harmful because they
respond in this cytokine storm this
hyper-aggressive immune reaction
uh which causes damage to the host
but what we're interested in is can we
look at not just the pro-inflammatory
cytokines but other host responses that
could have a diagnostic or prognostic
potential
some of these uh pro-inflammatory
cytokines have been published with you
know moderate to good
diagnostic or prognostic potential and
we're trying to see if we can look at
other molecules there as well
so the current diagnostics for covert 19
the gold standard test uh is a reverse
transcription
pcr which really targets in on that
viral genome which is you know it's a
very good test but it requires
relatively high viral load to accurately
detect infection and this this means
that it
shows it can show poor sensitivity um
particularly in the early stages of the
disease as that virus is starting to
replicate um and not quite at that
levels that can be detected by that pcr
test
in fact there was a paper that came out
just recently that showed that the
sensitivity can actually be as low as 30
to 40
in symptomatic patients luckily that's
not the norm um but there is high rates
of false negative particularly in that
pre and asymptomatic period
where that virus itself is not easily
detectable
and as i said what we're looking at is
can we identify a host response rather
than looking at the virus itself to
actually identify these covert 19 cases
with more sensitivity and more accuracy
so we work in a field of study focused
really squarely at host biomarkers and
these are indirect measures of health
using some sort of biological marker and
there's a lot of examples out there um
in medicine currently um you know
cardiac troponin in blood and measure of
heart attack uh blood glucose level as a
measure of diabetes and of course
pathogen-specific antibodies as an
indicator of infection
so our particular group we like to look
at circulating biomarkers and obviously
this is my beautiful drawing of the
blood vessel
but we look at circulating biomarkers in
basically any biological fluid you can
think of
and when we look at the current research
a lot of people are looking at
mainly three different classes of
biomarkers although there are others
that people look at and these are
proteins including antibody responses
cell-free dna including epigenetic
modifications or you know dna
methylation of cell-free dna and of
course micrornas and it's really these
um small non-coding rnas that's a main
focus of our particular team and it's
probably it's been a focus of mine
probably for the uh probably the past
six or so years ever since i
completed my phd
so
i'm going to spend just a little bit of
time chatting about micrornas
particularly for those of you who may
not know what micrornas are
i kind of always tell people that they
are my favorite molecules so i like to
always have a bit of a chat about what
these things are and what they do
in your body
so when i have a chat about micron a
function i like to go right back to the
very basics so the core of molecular
biology is that we start off with a dna
which is a blueprint in this case a
beautiful blueprint of a little lego man
and when we want to express or build a
particular section of that blueprint we
take a photocopy which is our rna or our
messenger rna we then hand it over to
our ribosomal builder which then
produces the final
protein product
now if this
dna rna protein as i said it's the the
core tenet of molecular biology if this
is kind of left unchecked you end up
with more protein product than you
actually want the builders will keep
building it as long as that rna hangs
around so there's lots of different
mechanisms to actually regulate this
process um but one of the main ones
that is a real central player in
cellular development and function is
micrornas and they really come in as a
bit of a shredder uh of course not this
sort of shredder this sort of shredder
that was for my teenage ninja turtle
fans um so the micrornas
are able to actually
bind and knock down the messenger rna
which then leads to a reduction in the
final protein product and in this way
they help to regulate that endogenous
gene expression
now of course it's much more um
complicated in real life and in cellular
biology than you know playing with lego
um so what we can see here is that the
pro the micrornas are uh transcribed in
these multi-hairpin
uh primary microrna structures
which are then cleaved into these
pre-microrna structures exported out of
the nucleus cleaved again by dicer into
the mature micrornas that we can see
over here and then there one of the
strands is incorporated into the
rna-induced silencing complex and this
is an argonaut protein complex that uses
that mrna to identify the target mr
micron aid to identify the target mrna
and when they find it they can either
cause
translational repression through
imperfect complementarity and this means
that
the argonal complex binds and will not
let it pass through the ribosome and
won't let it actually translate into
protein
or there's perfect complementarity which
results in mrna cleavage and
removal
now why am i talking about these in
terms of biomarkers if they've got such
an important role within the cell
what we've actually found over the years
is that
these micrornas can actually be released
into circulation and this could be
either due to cell stress or cell death
and a reduction in the membrane
integrity
they can be released either as naked
micro rna molecules or they can be bound
to lipoproteins or argonal proteins as
we can see over here onto the right
but they can also be uh packaged up and
released in these uh extracellular
vesicles uh known as exosomes and this
is an active
process and can be used as cell to cell
communication
now what's really cool about these
particular molecules is that they show
remarkable stability within circulation
they are resistant to degradation um by
endogenous nucleases they can withstand
multiple freeze thorough cycles changes
in temperature changes in ph they're
quite stable and good in terms of you
know
diagnostic biomarkers
we've also seen that micrornas are
present and detectable in basically any
biological fluid you could you could
imagine it i extracted them from pretty
much every biological fluid you can
imagine uh including urine tears saliva
you know cerebral spinal fluid obviously
serum and plasma
which makes them a really good sort of
peripheral
bio biomarker
for any sort of localized disease
now there are a couple of other benefits
of using micrornas as biomarkers which
i'll which i'll go into now so one of
the main
benefits of using these over say
detecting the virus is
looking at early detection and what we
can see over here on the right hand side
is that as time progresses and as the
replication of the virus really kicks
off or the pathogen really kicks off
we often see in a lot of diseases that
the options for treatment start to
decline
and really the earlier the better in a
lot of these infections
um and that's
uh and what we see a lot in these sort
of infections is that the in the early
stages of these infections the
diagnostics often fail they're not great
particularly in that incubation period
before the replication of the pathogen
really kicks off and this is either due
to
the diagnostic targeting the pathogen
and as i said that needs relatively high
replication to be
able to easily be found and this is
again the case in in covet 19 or they're
targeting something like antibodies
against uh the the pathogen which takes
at least a week but generally longer uh
to appear and be easily detectable
in contrast microrna changes are
actually detectable within three hours
that we've we've measured them in vitro
and 24 hours in vivo after infection um
you know this data came from a
publication that we that our team uh put
out in about 2013 and what was
interesting about this particular work
in hendra virus is that we were actually
able to to measure the changes of these
micrornas days before we were able to
detect the virus so they're rapidly
changing and easily detectable
another benefit of microrna biomarkers
is that it enables us to really drill
down
to the specific pathogen that causes the
disease and
this this is essentially the case that
many diseases share very either very
similar symptoms or in fact some
diseases can be caused by multiple
pathogens
and there was a publication back out in
2011 that had a look at hand foot and
mouth disease which is caused by
multiple different um
viruses and they were actually able to
use micrornas to distinguish between two
positive agents called sacchi virus 16
and enterovirus 71.
we've actually been able to drill down
even further than that and have a look
at viral strain specific responses um
and in this particular case this is
unpublished data this is in some of the
rabies work that i've done it's now
under review and hopefully we'll be out
soon
where we can look at different strains
of lissa virus actually elicit different
microinate responses
this is really important when the
treatment depends on the pathogen and if
we if we take into account um covert 19
obviously it's a respiratory disease
there are many viruses that can cause
respiratory diseases one of the major
ones is influenza uh and knowing whether
it's covert 19 or influenza really makes
a big impact on that treatment on that
clinical decisions on how that patient
is treated um you know and particularly
in the case of influenza they have uh
tammy fluent and other
ways of actually treating that infection
there as well
all right so we'll get into the meat of
the study uh this is uh talking about
the covert 19 micrornas study that we
completed
it was published fairly recently in plos
pathogens
um and
the aim of this particular study it had
had sort of three aims
the first one was to identify any sort
of changes in circulating in this case
it was plasma micrornas in human
patients with covert 19 compared to
healthy controls
investigate whether a micronic biomarker
signature could be used to identify or
predict
sars cf2 infection and then we went on
to validate these results in an animal
model
so first up we took plasma from 10
covert 19 patients and 10
healthy age and gender match controls
and we can also see that the covert 19
patients almost half of them had to or
required supplementary oxygen therapy
there as well
what was really good about this
particular cohort of patients was that
they were
sampled longitudinally so
we were actually able to assess some of
these samples over time to see you know
whether the biomarker signature faded
away whether it changed over time so
most of the work that i'm going to show
you here was really focused on this v1
the the very earliest visit
that was taken from these particular
individuals so we're looking at an acute
and early phase microneed response
so all the samples that we collected
from all of these patients went through
micrornas sequencing and if anybody's
done microrna sequencing before you'll
know that there are a few sequencing
hurdles if you want to
have a look at these particular
molecules and one of them particularly
in the case of circulation is you do
tend to get a very low rna yield from
circulation and this can
make it quite difficult with you know a
lot of your traditional library
preparation kits to actually get enough
to generate a nice complete library
they're also quite a small or quite a
short rna species and this has kind of
necessitated a lot of
gel excision to try and kind of cut out
the size of rna that you want to then go
down into the
cdna library preparation
so of course this is a kaizen kaijan uh
sponsored webinar we use the kaya seek
my current a library kit uh it's a
two-day protocol it was it was actually
yeah surprisingly easy to do
um there was no sort of sense of
gel size selection which made my life a
little bit easier uh and i was actually
able to tweak the protocol with a lot of
help from the kyogen technical support
to kind of tweak it to my needs which
i'm very appreciative of
and this resulted in quite a lot of very
nice data um
so here we can see that we um
we sliced out uh all the reeds that were
about 18 to 26 nucleotides long really
to capture those micrornas species
there as well
no there's not a huge amount of
unmapped reeds that you can see there at
the top which is really nice to see and
a lot of the too short or too long often
come from other rna species particularly
the too long we often see a lot of pee
rnas which are you know 30 nucleotides
or so
and so
that's where a lot of those reeds are
coming from but for all of our samples
we were getting you know in the tens of
millions of reads to work with which was
really nice to see
so
first step was to have a look at the
differential expression so what is
actually changing in the circulation of
these patients and what we found is
about 55 micron a's of a total of
approximately 800 that were detected uh
were significantly altered using a false
discovery rate of less than 0.05 using
dc normalization
um
within uh perfect 19 patients and it's
kind of a relatively even split we get
about 30 that are down regulated uh 20
that are up regulated and five which
were up regulated but just weren't quite
over that twofold change
now we went along and obviously did qpcr
validation on a few of these markers
just to give us confidence that what we
were seeing in the ngs was
absolutely
you know a reflection of what we were
actually seeing and confidence in that
ngs data
now when we actually had a look at these
individual micrornas we found that our
most upregulated
micronesimo31 which has a real
established role in inflammation and our
most significantly down regulated
micrornas is no 766 which had an
anti-inflammatory role and so what we
can actually see is a role for these
microrna responses in covert patients
in terms of inflammation and that kind
of tracks with a lot of the previous
data which has shown these changes in
these pro-inflammatory
cytokines in fact we were able to access
some data from these particular patients
around their cytokine changes we're able
to validate that in fact we did see a
significant increase in il6 there as
well
now if we take
all 55 of those differentially expressed
micrornas and we put them into a
principal component analysis we can see
that there is really nice separation
between these two groups that's really
nice we see that
the micron microrna responses are giving
us this separation between the groups
but in terms of a diagnostic use this is
pretty unrealistic no diagnostic lab is
going to be running 55 separate tests to
tell whether you have coveted or not
it's just it's not going to work
so we kind of thought how are we going
to bring
55 down to a manageable level how are we
going to figure out
what are the most important micro rnas
for detecting or predicting covert 19.
so we turned uh to machine learning
and this is a branch of artificial
intelligence and if you actually go out
and google machine learning you get some
fantastic
images that are always in blue for some
reason of you know circuitry with you
know human faces or um
mines melded together or my particular
favorite is this wonderful uh pensive
looking robot pouring over
you know different mathematical
equations but really when you think
about when you learn about what machine
learning really is this is probably more
accurate
it's a big pile of maths a big pile of
linear algebra that you're able to
actually pour in your data
you know
change the coefficients of the equation
and then see how well it works and if it
doesn't work very well you're able to
kind of keep working with it keep
tweaking it
until it starts to look right until that
model is performing how you
hope
a lot of people are worried about
machine learning you know machine
learning is not skynet
often times particularly when you're
first starting this is the kind of
results that you're going to get
this is a neural network which is a more
advanced machine learning algorithm and
obviously you can see here it's not
doing so well in the prediction space
all right so i used a process known as
supervised machine learning and there's
really two parts
to this approach the first part is to
provide labeled data or training data to
the machine learning algorithm
and in this case in the example on the
screen there it's cats or not cats uh in
my case it was infected or not infected
and the machine then learns
what the different
markers or
yeah what what the different features
that are important to distinguishing one
from another
and then once it's done that you can
then test it by giving it unlabeled data
so data it's never seen before it has no
idea uh whether these are cats or not
cats or infected or uninfected um and it
has to then predict which group those
unlabeled data fit into and then you can
evaluate how well it did you can have a
look at its accuracy and sensitivity and
things like that
but one of the main uh problems with
this when you're talking about you know
lower sample numbers and a lot of
micrornas remembering that you know we
found about 800 detectable micrornas
within patients is how do we actually
bring it down to a
the right amount or the optimal amount
of micrornas to enable us to one have
not too many molecules for a diagnostic
test but also still have really high
levels of accuracy
so
what i did is i
created a model with all of the
micrornas all 800 and then we're able to
rank these micrornas on their importance
or how much did they contribute
to this model's performance
i then took out the very top the most
important microrna
and randomly split the data into again
that training and testing it was
randomly done into 70 training 30
testing
and then i trained the model tested the
model and then evaluated how well it
performed just on that one top micro rna
and of course it's not science if you
don't record the results right
and then i'd go back and i'd do this a
thousand times to make sure that i'm
really confident
in the evaluation of that model
and once i've done all of this i go
right the way back and i add in the next
micrornas so the next time i do it with
the top two micrornas go through this
process you know assess it a thousand
times record the results and in this
iterative process we start to get a bit
of an idea about as we add in more
micronase what is that doing to the
accuracy of the model and where do we
get to a point where it is the optimal
level of micrornas for our predictive
model
and so when we actually have a look at
machine learning there's a few different
results metrics that we look at and the
main one obviously is accuracy how many
of those predictions were correct
now this is
probably your default metric for a lot
of things
but there are certain situations where
accuracy may not be the greatest one if
you have something where 99 of your
tests are expected to be negative and
one percent are expected to be positive
you could just call them all negative
and you'd have a 99
accurate model it's not always the best
measure
so we also look at things like precision
which is how many of the predicted
positives were actually positive or your
true positive rate
recall which is how many of the true
positives did the model find and this is
also called sensitivity so when you're
trying to compare these two
and the receiver operating
characteristic area under the curve or
rock ac and this is really just a very
succinct metric to describe the overall
diagnostic ability of a binary or a one
versus another infected and non-infected
cats not cats whatever sort of
classifier you want to talk about
so what we can see here is the results
of that
feature selection or that micron a
selection we can see that even just
starting with one microrna the top
microrna gave us actually above 90
percent accuracy but once we hit three
micrornas that's where we see our
optimal
and these are the three micrornas that
form that signature uh and we can see
that it's really close to 100 accurate
um precise and
uh sensitive there and kind of adding in
more and more micrornas really doesn't
improve uh the model very much at all so
going from 55 differentially expressed
micrornas down to three uh in a machine
learning model
what's really interesting about these
guys these particular micrornas is that
this they're not the most abundant one
is quite um high abundance so merge
four two three um
one is kind of middling and 195 is not
low but it's you know on the lower end
of the scale there uh what we also see
is they're not the most differentially
uh expressed either we have some that
are you know one that's down two that's
up but they're not you know sitting out
here right on the fringes
and when we actually have a look at the
micrornas only two of them
actually came up in the differential
expression analysis so mer-23a
looks like it's uh down-regulated but
it's non-significant
whereas the other two are up regulated
and so this it's an interesting
comparison between what's found
via
the machine learning versus what is in
the machine
learning model there as well
so when we actually have a look at how
well this um predictive signature works
uh after that sort of a thousand random
iterations we actually get about a 99.9
accuracy 99.8
precision and again 99.9 recall or
sensitivity uh using just those three
micrornas and when we actually plot this
uh using a pca we see a really nice
separation between those two groups and
what we can see here as well is this has
the probability of each of these samples
being classified as infected with covert
19. what we can see is that the healthy
is
basically zero percent probability
pervert 19 is 100
probability and that probability only
starts to kind of waver right near that
decision line which is this black line
that you can see uh dividing those two
groups so it was a highly confident
model
what was interesting is then when we
could look at the further visits um
visit two three and four of these
individuals uh as they started getting
better as they started clearing this
disease
most of the samples started
congregating and grouping back with the
healthy controls down here
now there is an obvious exception to
this rule um visit 2 3 and 4 denoted
here by the hash symbol
these were from one individual who was
in icu and was actually sick through all
visits and
their
samples clustered more with the infected
signature so this
kind of suggests that it's a signature
of really early disease that starts to
fade away over time as people start to
clear that disease
all right so we we found this um
particular signature in um you know a
smallish number of patients and we
wanted to then go okay can we validate
this using an animal model and we used
ferrets as the
preferred animal model
they're used quite significantly in
terms of respiratory viral infections
particularly influenza
so we used a ferret model where 20
ferrets
were uh intranasally inoculated with
sars cov2
and they were seriously sacrificed on
different days and on each one of these
days we also had
nasal swabs washes and bloods taken
now what we can see um so this is the
sars here v2 qpcr results we can see
that even from day three um most of them
show uh positivity particularly in the
turbine in the
nasal wash and oral swabs but it starts
to decrease over the days in fact by day
14 it's only detectable in the lymph
nodes and not anywhere else
so to really validate the human microrna
signature we investigated serum from
ferrets that were either uninfected
uh infected with sars here v2 or just to
kick up the diff uh difficulty a little
bit uh infected with influenza or h1n1
strain
what we can see is when we put together
a pca based on these three micrornas we
can already see that they're starting to
kind of cluster out pretty nicely we've
got our uninfected over here in blue
h1n1 down there in orange and the sarsia
v2 infected
ferrets there in green and you can see
that they are actually starting to
cluster out without doing anything to
them apart from looking at those three
micrornas
and when we actually just look at um
ferrets infected with sciatica v2 versus
those that are uninfected we get again
about over 99
accuracy and actually 100 recall and
rocket auc and we get this really nice
uh really confident model between um
these two groups it's really nice to see
kind of validating what we had seen in
the human cohort but again i guess one
of the questions we get asked a lot is
can this differentiate between multiple
different infections and that's why we
brought in the influenza the h1n1
infected
ferrets there as well
the good news is it can so
we had a look at again using these three
micrornas
to
assess whether we could uh differentiate
between uninfected sarzia v2 infected
and h1n1 infected ferrets and the
accuracy of this is still pretty high
it's about 95
accurate in determining uh or predicting
whether these samples belong to one of
these three groups
and what you can see is actually one of
the misclassifications that's done there
which would be pulling down this
accuracy score it's misclassifying one
of the h1n1 infected ferrets as sars
cov2 that you can see down there on the
white dot there or the light dot
all right so i'm just going to spend a
couple of minutes having a bit of a chat
about some of the newest data that we've
started to put together
so oftentimes what we get asked about is
what about
non-invasive nasal swabs um wouldn't
that be better than plasmart you know
this is the the normal test that people
get done it's the one that feels like
it's tickling the back of your brain
but this is the normal way of of
detecting copper 19. can we do the same
thing here would upper respiratory
micrornas allow
for covert 19
identification
and if so would those signatures or
would those micrornas that are used for
identification would they be the same as
what we identified in the plasma
so what we did is we collected nasal
swabs
from
12 covet 19 patients and eight
uninfected symptom-free controls
and interestingly we did find again when
we took the same approach of identifying
these micrornas feeding them into a
machine learning model that again the
optimal was sitting up there at about
three mic rnas
we actually ended up getting a hundred
percent uh accuracy precision recall and
rock and you see across the board which
was surprising but absolutely fantastic
um and again we get this really nice
separation um and here we have a pca
plot between the two different groups
based again on just three micro rnas
what was interesting is that
they are not the same three micro rnas
these are a completely different
signature in the upper respiratory tract
that allows this differentiation between
um covert 19 and control or uninfected
individuals
again we see two that are significantly
different so
you can see here six to eight and 93
show
chop in the differential expression
analysis but 30c does not even though
there's a trend it is non-significant in
differential expression analysis
so
kind of showing you that
we can still do it it's still a three
macron a signature it still works
phenomenally well but it's a different
set of micrornas and it may be just
localized uh to that particular sample
type if you want to learn more about
this particular research we do have a
preprint available on research square
it's under review at the moment and
hopefully we'll get that published out
as well
all right so getting into the summary uh
what have we done and what's next uh so
circulating micrornas uh respond to
sarsia v2 infection we found a large
proportion of micrornas that did change
in response to 55 differentially
expressed
micrornas we found a signature of three
plasma micrornas that can independently
classify covet 19 with 99.9
accuracy
and this signature is actually robust in
an animal model there as well with about
99.7 percent accuracy uh looking between
uh covert 19 also cv2 infection uh and
uninfected ferrets and can actually
distinguish between uninfected sarcia v2
and seasonal influenza h1n1 infected
ferrets with about 95 accuracy and this
includes cases uh
later on in the disease progression
where nasal swab pcr results were
actually negative
and we found a different set of three
micron a signature
that uh classifies copic 19 with 100
accuracy using that sort of nasal swab
media
now what's next um we're looking into
biomarker validation in larger patient
cohorts a lot of these obviously smaller
sample numbers um australia did quite
well at least in the initial parts of
this pandemic
so
samples weren't super easy to come by
we're hoping to to pad those numbers out
and really get into that biomarker
validation and have a look at sort of
clinical sensitivity and specificity and
we really want to have a look at really
interested in looking in those pre and
asymptomatic patients to really see how
well
this signature can work in that cohort
as well
and we're also looking into commercial
partnerships for translation either as a
lab-based test or a point of care test
and of course a very big thank you to
all the people who helped out in this
particular study um i will definitely
acknowledge cam stuart or cameron
stewart down there
who's the team lead for host response
here at csiro um
chris khalid who helped with a lot of
the bioinformatics work um and actually
trained me to use python so all this
stuff wouldn't have been without his
help uh and of course chrissy roots uh
who does a lot of the high containment
virology work so a big thank you to all
those guys um we worked a lot with the
peter doherty alfred health uh who
enabled us to actually access these
samples
and of course the dangerous pathogens
team which is glenn gough and vassan in
particular uh who helped us out with the
the ferret infection work as well
so with that i'm going to leave you um
say a big thank you to everybody for
listening uh and again thank you to uh
kai jin for inviting me to give this
seminar if anybody's interested uh or
has any extra questions after this
you're more than welcome to to drop me a
line i've got my details down there
twitter handle and we actually have our
website that we've just put up if you
want to learn more about the work that
we do so thank you very much
thank you so much ryan that was really
interesting um
i find it incredible to have three
signatures like that that could be so
so predictive and then to be able to
differentiate also between that and the
flu which is i find just really
interesting
um i do want to invite our
attendees now if you'd like to find your
chat box or your question box on your
desktop to go ahead and type in a
question if you have a question for ryan
and we'll give you just a few seconds to
do that
and then we'll start our q and a session
for this evening
we have a first question here
how did you choose your machine learning
model
ah that's a good one yeah so anybody
who's ever been involved uh in machine
learning at all knows that there's a
multitude of different machine learning
models out there and it can be quite
difficult to
pick one to go for what what is the one
that i want to do how do i
um set up my data so that it works well
that the model uh works well and so what
we've actually done is and you know it's
a lot of the work that i've done with
chris khalid there is to set up a data
analysis pipeline and so what this
pipeline does is that we feed in the
data and then it tries to look at
multiple different machine learning
models it also looks at different things
like whether we pca transform the data
how we scale it there's so many
different tweaks that you can do to this
analysis
and as it runs through this data
analysis pipeline
we're able to generate a report at the
end which shows us all the different
options it shows us um you know how many
micrornas uh what particular model how
we scale the data how we work with the
data and so we can sort of have a look
at that uh report at the end of all that
and say okay we want three micrornas or
five micrornas uh we also want it to be
pca transformed we want to use logistic
regression or support vector machine or
k-nearest neighbors or whatever model we
want to use but by doing this and this
is kind of the power of learning those
kind of bioinformatics skills and
pipeline skills is that you can
investigate all of these different
things all at once it's not not a case
of going into the lab having to
troubleshoot and go backwards and
forwards as you can tell i'm a bit of a
bioinformatic convert here but
it means that you're able to kind of
look at all these different variations
and pick the best one that works for you
and your data and in this case a lot of
the times it's the simplest oftentimes
we end up using a logistic regression
model which is fairly simple but it
seems to be fairly powerful but at least
we have all those options to look at
everything
great thank you so much um
we have another question here could this
micro rna signature be used to detect
asymptomatic or pre-symptomatic
infections
yeah excellent so this is
a lot of the work that we want to do in
the future we are hoping to you know
recruit patients and get those sort of
longitudinal pre-symptomatic and
asymptomatic
samples as we go along
but
based on our previous research in other
viruses
we're pretty confident that this
signature will work
i think i mentioned there one of the
publications that we did back in 2013
this was in hendra virus as was looking
at the changes in circulating micrornas
in response to hendra virus and what we
were actually able to see is that
the changes in circulating micrornas
were detectable and easily detectable
days before we actually found that virus
and this is because they they change
really rapidly in response to stimuli
and this may not be infectious disease
this could be stress this could be
heat this could be all sorts of
different things can can change the
response
of microrna expression but because it
acts so rapidly you know in cell culture
it's sort of within that three hours we
can start seeing uh extracellular so um
circulating micrornas changing and
within an in vivo system and animals or
humans we can generally see them start
to change within that 24-hour period and
so what we're hoping for is to validate
the signature in those individuals who
are being infected but may not have
developed symptoms
and there again is some some extra data
that i'm hoping to publish i've got too
many too many papers to put together
that we're hoping to publish that shows
again this real
pre-symptomatic changes in these
micrornas in viral infections and so
we're really confident that we that
we're able to do that as well awesome
awesome
um another question here why weren't all
of the uh micro rnas in the covet
signature
differentially expressed
yeah it's something that we see uh
fairly regularly
so i guess there's a
fairly big difference between uh
differential expression analysis and
machine learning analysis so
your differential expression analysis
looks at each individual microrna and
just compares just that one it's known
as a univariate analysis it just looks
at one variable and it looks at the two
groups and it says statistically
how likely are we to see this change by
random chance
um and then it goes through and says
okay you know within that threshold
that's statistically significant then it
moves on to the next one and the next
one
but when you're looking at 800 odd
micrornas it's got to control
for doing 800 different statistical
tests and that you know
that ends up being a lot of p-value
adjustment and sometimes that p-value
adjustment can be
too stringent and so you end up cutting
off a lot that
show a trend and that you know in the
unadjusted p-value are actually
significant but because of these p-value
adjustment become unsignificant
or non-significant i should say
with the machine learning model
it doesn't really take that into account
it looks at the expression of all the
micrornas within the model and how they
relate to one another so this is a
multi-variate
analysis
and so
this looks at not just one in isolation
but it looks at all in this case three
of those micrornas and the relationship
between one that may go up one that may
go down one that may not change all that
much
um but how those then feed into that uh
equation which underlies the the machine
learning model um and how they all sort
of fit together and for me
it's more
reflective of what's happening at a
biological level um if we're infected
with viruses if we're stressed in a
particular way
we don't just see one gene change or one
microrna change in isolation to
everything else and everything else
staying the same there's always this
interaction between the micrornas
between the gene expression between the
proteins between the virus and so
looking at it in that multivariate
analysis
enables us to kind of get a bit more
power it also gives us a bit more of a
biological insight into what's happening
in this biological system
excellent thank you
um i think we have time maybe for one
more question
um
this person says what about vaccinated
people would they show up as positive
using this test
so this is something that a lot of
diagnostic tests have struggled with
over the years
that differentiation between
current infection
and vaccinated uh individuals and
particularly when you're looking at
tests that are uh looking into
antibodies and those sort of
responses that you know can crop up
because of vaccination or because of um
current infection sometimes it can be
very difficult to split out those two
now what we've seen again um i don't
have the data for covert 19 but
obviously with more and more people
getting vaccinated
and our rates are pumping up here in
australia which is fantastic um we'll be
able to to hopefully do that
work but in our previous work and again
in hendra virus which is a highly
pathogenic virus
we've seen that
vaccinated
individuals
show up the same as uninfected
individuals in terms of their micro rna
response
unlike your antibody response micrornas
don't need to hang around um for you
know the the life they're not an immune
they impact on the immune response but
they're not like antibodies which are
you know hanging around to give you that
protection they are often
short-term things they respond to a
stimuli in this case infection
um and so we're actually able to split
out those too and have a look at it
have a look at those those vaccinated
individuals coming up as uninfected
individuals and so
we're really confident that by looking
at the micro rna signatures
that we're able to also
not get confused with vaccinated
individuals because they're two slightly
different things they're looking at two
two uh different classes of molecules i
hope that i hope that answers that
question
terrific thank you so much um
i would like to tell our audience if you
did not get your question answered um
during this session or if you go back to
your lab bench and maybe tomorrow think
about some questions that you might have
for us please feel free to contact us at
kyah webinars at
kyogen.com and that address is showing
on your screen right now and we'll be
happy to get back to you with an answer
so again i would like to uh thanks so
much ryan for just a very impressive
presentation today and some really
interesting data and i think insights
into
covid
i want to thank our audience for joining
us today
and uh
this i think then concludes today's
webinar presentation thank you and have
a great rest of your day
you